abone ol
ne Dyo typing
dersimizin konusu Almanca saatler yani
biz bu derste saat kaç demeyi ve buna
hem resmi hem günlük dilde cevap vermeye
öğrencisi yani saatimizi söyleyeceğiz
Bununla ilgili PDF dosyası ve oyun
alıştırma linkleri videonun Açıklama
kısmında kanalıma destek olmak için
abone olmayı unutmayın
iyi bilmemiz gereken bazı kelimeler var
Bunları bilirsiniz ezberlersin iz işimiz
çok kolay nedir bunlar Öncelikle soru
sormam Saat kaç Saat kaç iki türlü ifade
edilir ve şüphe test test test ya da
lifin Oo istese ikisi de aynı şey cevap
verirken hep aynı kalıp kullanılır hem
resmi hem Günlükleri de es Bu kadar
basit bir de diğer kelimelerdi lua
soğan aktivite help
ve informel o Whatsapp resmi olmayan
günlük dilde kullandığımız saat
bilgisiyle başlayalım
ses bu bizim kalıbımız Öncelikle tam
saatleri öğrenelim Yani diyelim ki saat
bir saat 2.00 gibi görüp Dize Biz 12'lik
saat dilimini kullanırız Bu ne demek
yani saat 13 yerine saat bir deriz ya da
18 demeyi saat
600 da Deniz 12 deriz O yüzden saat bir
ya da 13 bunun ikisi aynı şeyler Bunları
aynı şekilde ifade etmemiz gerekir
es-es'e Einstein kelimesi kelimenin
sonunda ise s harfi gelirer kelimenin
sonunda değilse arkasından başka kelime
geliyor ise s harfi düşer Örneğin Es
aynı da diyebilirsiniz eşsiz aynı odada
diyebilirsiniz Onun dışında 2.00 ya da
14es vay o A3 Astra Yoo O Ses Türkiye
Oasis ünyada esasül o gibi o kelimesini
kullansanız da olur kullanmazsanız da
olur bu
da tam olmayan saatler tamamlayan
Saatler ne demek yani saat 1.10 25
geçiyor ya da 20 kala gibi yani burada
bize iki tane kelime lazım o da nedir
Bir tanesi Tabii ki geçi yani la ya da
kala O da foua bu iki kelime bize
gerekli bunları bir kenara yazalım
burada Türkçe'den farklı bir durum var o
da nedir bir saat önce söyleriz ama
Almanca'da önce dakika ifade edilir
dakika soyadan Ah edatı ve saat gelir
Örneğin saat 3.05 derken önce beşi
söylememiz lazım
esest fnaf Nah Thai ya da saat 2.55
derken yine önce dakikayı söylemeliyiz
eski sırt Fuat hay gibi
bu esvan siz nasıl Birds
o eskisi ben noxin
bu ses ki sırf onu Senses nah zibam
bu
eskisin zsuat Die
esfer foah t bu ses sen sen iş fazla
seks
bu fiyatı yani çeyrekli ifadeler yine
aynı şekilde fiyatı önce gelir fiyat ne
demek fiyat 4 demek yani bir saate dörde
böldük siyah fiyatı kelimesi 4'ten gelir
fiyatı çeyrek demek fiyatını önce yazlık
Ve arkasından soyadan Ah Vedat'ı ve en
sona ise saat bilgisi gelirken aynı
mantık
essest fiyat Info esesti fiyatına gibi
bu esfiya tırnağı söz
o eski fiyatına sen
o eski fiyatı Fuat Su bayi
o eski fiyatı soğan zıbın
Ben yaramaz saatler ifade ederken çok
dikkatli olmalıyız Çünkü burada işin
içinde biraz bir tuhaflık var Nedir o
tuhaflık yarımı saatleri ifade ederken
Türkçe'den farklı olarak bir sonraki
saati sikr ederiz yani saat üç buçuk
yerine saat dört buçuk deriz bir sonraki
saati baz alırız 3.30
Estel daha yerine Estel pfi ya dememiz
gerekir
bu Help is Help and ses Help ev
bu ses helps Vay
ses type senin gibi
bu form Allah at sight resmi saat
bilgisiyle devam edelim Bu işin kolay
kısmı resmi saat bilgisini söylemek çok
basit Düz mantık soldan başlayarak Tan
sağa doğru okuruz ve burada 24 saat
dilimi geçerli yani ne görüyorsanız onu
okumalısınız Örneğin sıfır gördüğünüz
Eses Nova arkasına Ova kelimesinin
koymamız lazım
esnova bu sondaki sıfırlar ise okunmaz
estay senua
esas olduğu gibi okudum o eski fialova
sonuç seyin
bu ses One S şu a
kaysis gibi burada çeyrek yarım gibi
ifadeler yok olduğu gibi okuyorsunuz
o unutmayın resmi dilde saat ifade
ederken 24 saatlik zaman dilimini baz
alıyorduk olduğu gibi okuyorduk ve o
kelimesi bize gerekli oluyordu resmi
olmayan günlük dilde ise bu kelimesini
pek kullanmayız soğana fiyatın Harp gibi
ifadeleri kullanırız burada isterseniz
videoyu durdurup kendinizi
deneyebilirsiniz
Evet Ee stylance fancy Şua
bu esest Nova
esest frowas cipsin
diest cipsin nafia
bu
es-es'te vova full Scene
bu EST fiyatına herkes
bu ses Find squada İSG ses her Pers
bu ses tahta Oh afiyet ses ses
lenses for knowing
bu ses ver Fight Scene bu ses Selena söz
ses Nova zîlan fiyatı ses ses tyt sen
feuds
Siz dersinizi örneklerle tamamlayalım
son baş kildiş fetus ve ses fenty kova
eşsiz Aha to a wifi luise
sessiz Santi kova from Sting eşsiz
fiyatında aht diş fetus test
sest monte kuat Ice iş
[Müzik]
snowinn
füruğ
istese spanswick o Ateş üst sansit
fonite dersimiz sona erdi Dyo kopya
Hamdi boğa diye Hamdi saat der bir
Afrika Sözü Bir sonraki derste görüşmek
üzere hoşçakalın